why do 99% of writers fail
Corey so so many writers have a dream to
succeed and they work really hard to
learn the skills to grow their talent
and they're really
dedicated and they they don't succeed
and they feel like well you know I've
learned all these tools and I work all
the time and I guess they don't have
what it
takes I want if you ever find yourself
in that place I want you to remember
something that there's three things that
are required there's a missing piece so
yes skill talent talent is repeatable
skills you have to be able to write in
Conflict you have to be able to write
great characters and dialogue and
heightened Concepts yes all of that yes
and you're going to probably have to
work hard to develop that but once you
do and you have that Talent you
obviously need dedication right you have
all the talent in the world if you don't
work hard not going to happen okay you
have all the talent have all the
dedication and you can fail which then
tells people I guess I don't have what
it takes I want you to think about Bruce
Springstein he's pretty good right uh
he's not a rock and roll star he's a
rock and roll God and I think he would
agree incredibly talented I think you
degree incredibly dedicated he didn't go
to college he didn't get married he was
just playing music all the time for like
10 years for no money just he was all in
on his dream and work so hard on his
ability he got a record deal at Colombia
he had a year to make his album they
supported him with money and background
music and they promoted the heck out of
it and went out and it bombed the great
Bruce bingin bombed I gave him a second
chance because they saw his potential so
he spent another year and just p i mean
everything into the second album and
they spent so much money on promotion
it's Bruce Springsteen so you know what
happened that second album bombed
it's very easy at this point to say PA's
pretty good at music made two albums the
biggest record company in the world is
promoting it nobody wants to listen to
it I guess I don't have what it
takes but God Smiled On Bruce
Springsteen and he got a third chance
and his third album was Born to Run and
his third album is one of the most
successful records of all time it sold
tens of millions of copies it made him a
rock and roll God in the 1970s if you
want to be famous there's two things you
could do get on the cover of Newsweek or
get on the cover of Time magazine in the
same week Bruce Springsteen was on the
cover of Newsweek and time no other
musician has ever done that so I have a
question for you what was different from
the third album from the first two
albums he had all the talent he had all
the dedication but there was something
missing it's not luck there now luck
involved luck is what the losers point
to Born to Run is a
Transcendent magical album it would have
been so successful if it came out 10
years earlier 10 years Heck if it came
out today as a brand new album it would
be amazing what is different if you are
serious about writing or acting or
directing or whatever your creative
Pursuit is you need to know this answer
what was different and what was
different was John land
John Lando was a writer for the Rolling
Stone discovered Bruce knew that Bruce
was just a generational talent and after
the second album he went to Bruce and
said can I be your producer can I
produce your third album and they met
and they talked and Bruce trusted him
and respected him and Bruce said yes now
John L did not produced the first album
did not produce the second album he
produced Born to Run and what I'm about
about to say is something that Bruce
Springstein and John landow have said
publicly many times so I'm just sharing
what they
said John Lando said that what he needed
to do was adjust not very much but he
had adjust Bruce's
process we live in a world where people
ignore process they they focus on
results success or failure process is
how you create
product I can always track the best
scripts back to the best process and I
work with writers I can always track
their scripts that fail back to failed
process process process process if you
were a golfer and you weren't getting
the results you wanted you would see
someone who would break down your swing
and re engineer your swing because your
swing is your
process as a writer if you're writing
and not getting the results you want
what Writers Do Is they either quit or
they just double down and keep writing
scripts thinking well you got to be in
the right place at the right time time
and they keep writing and they create a
pile of similarly flawed scripts process
process process you have to improve your
process the great Bruce Springstein
needed an adjustment in process so who
can do that for
you managers can do that for you uh
mentors writers it's something I do in
my workshops and also one-on-one but not
taking one on one clients or if you
don't have the money or you don't have
the time uh you're fortunate to live in
a time when there's so much free digital
content so you can go back and watch if
you haven't already a lot of film
courage videos you can also go to
podcasts and there are a lot of writers
who talk about their process now it's
really important that you don't just
find a writer that you love and say oh
I'm going to do her process no no
no there is a process that allows Tina
Fay to write to the best of her ability
there's a process that allows you know
greda gerwick to write to the best of
her ability that's not the process is
going to allow you to write you got to
find your process so when I work with
writers I do process coaching and what I
always tell a writer and I specifically
want to tell this to any of you who
never work with me I always tell a
writer I am not smart enough to look at
your writing and talk to you and know
what process is going to work best for
you
you're not smart enough to know you have
to experiment I will tell you this most
writers default process holds them back
most writers default process plays to
their strengths and hides their
weaknesses and if you keep doing that
your weaknesses get weaker and your
strengths get stronger so when I do this
work with writers I will give them a
range of processes to use to see what
the results are and then we'll start to
f- tune and start to find your proc
process and you do not have to work with
me um it's cool that you can again if
you have some time and energy listen to
the film courage videos listen to
podcasts listen to very successful
writers they'll talk about their process
so you could start to collect lots of
different writers processes and you
could start playing with some of those
and experimenting with some of those if
you're not going to work with me let me
give you a piece of
advice find seven writers that you
really respect that that talk about
their process not all writers do but a
lot of writers do because there's so
much you know uh interviews out there so
find at least seven writers that you
respect who share their process and
write down what their process is and
then what I want you to do is look at
those processes those seven processes
and say which one do I think is going to
work best for me and then which one
would I be most excited to try it might
be the same one might be a different one
and then okay which one do I know isn't
going to work for me there's no way
start with that one
start with that one because writers I
always tell writers this either you
control your process or your process
controls you I'll just give you an
example I worked with a writer really
smart had a manager but couldn't get a
career and in working with their process
and getting to know them it became clear
that when they had a problem with their
script they had to make a really big
decision solve a big problem they'd get
anxious and stressed most people do and
they think about it until they could
find a really good solution then they'd
use it that's a flaw in your process so
what I said is okay so you have this
script and you have this problem and you
have this solution which makes a lot of
sense great I want you to pretend that
your agent said I cannot go out to the
market place with a script that has this
solution I need you to come up with a
different solution and you got to pitch
it to me in 3
days come back in 3 days and Pitch me
that solution and then I said okay I
want to pretend that your man your agent
said nope you have three days you get me
a different solution or I drop you and
come back in three days and then I do it
I'm going to have them do four or
five and here's what they're going to
realize some of the time their first one
the first good one they came up with is
the best sometimes the fourth one is the
best and I asked them do you want to
write the fastest script the easiest
script or the best script do you want a
chance of a career or you want the best
chance of the best possible
career So This Is What It Takes when
you're stuck on a problem don't use the
first good solution you come up with
that goes on the option list come up
with five seven other great options and
then I'll say I want you to think of the
worst option the the the way you know
would be a disaster and just go write
that real quick try all this out that's
that's what creativity is creativity is
an exploration and we often learn more
from our mistakes than our successes so
that's just one example of a process
glitch where smart people will have a
problem they'll think about it they'll
come up with their first good answer and
use it without exploring other options
and sometimes if they're pushed to do
that the sixth option they come up with
is going to be the reason they have a
career I'll give you one more example of
a process glitch I worked with another
writer super talented always Clos to her
career never had a career and in working
with her it became really clear that she
really connects with their characters
she really feels and sees them as real
people and she has like a a maternal
instinct to protect her
characters and so I started to give her
process training where she had to take
the character she loved the most and
just do the brutally worst things to
these characters she had to kill her
characters in the worst possible way it
was so painful but then when she was
done she's like you know that was kind
of fun I mean the character's still
there I'm still there and because if
you're protecting your characters if
you're protecting them from pain or
yourself from the pain you can only go
so far as a writer um you know the
reason Breaking Bad and flea bag and the
bear are so great is those writers are
so courageous they just go into their
pain and they write from there and they
do not protect the characters because we
want to have an emotional experience we
want to be emotionally
changed and this is it's really
important and I'd like to sort of talk
about
it if you permit me in a much bigger way
um um everything in life seems to divide
us and everyone's on
teams and one team has all the answers
and the other team are idiots and the
other team has all the answers and
they're an idiot and corporations and
governments often do things to keep us
aroused and angry and suspicious because
that is how they can keep our attention
and they can get us to watch and they
can get us to buy or to donate and this
is not a a prom for one side or the
other it's a prom for everyone let me
share a quote um a really great quote
from James Baldwin and he
says I imagine one of the reasons people
cling to their hate so stubbornly is
because they Sense Once hate is gone
they'll be forced to deal with their
pain and I think that's really
powerful uh I can resonate and connect
with that I think that
um there's a lot of pain that people
don't want to experience and we live in
a society that says don't deal with your
pain cope with your pain and one way of
coping with your pain is as medication
or alcohol or work a lot or sex or just
get really angry at the other side and
just live in this Perpetual
self-righteous
anger and I think as a society we've
sort of lost our ability to deal with
pain and you know we used to have
rituals when people died or terrible
things that we came together and there
were rituals but but a lot of those
rituals have fallen away in the modern
world and there's just a lot of hatred
and anger and fear because there's a lot
of pain that people don't want to face
and so it's so important that you can as
a writer write from that pain don't
protect your characters because that is
one of the ways you can help make the
role the better place is that you can
tell
stories like flea bag um um where
characters choose or forced to confront
their deepest
pain and come out the other side a
better person a more whole person a more
healthy person we need to Vally like you
can't just lecture people you can't just
people can't tell people to do that
they'll just tune you out but you create
a character that they they spend their
lives with that they're viscerally
connected to they get to experience that
or you could do the opposite
like succession or the bear where you
can have characters who refuse refuse to
deal with their inner pain and they just
live in
this just this aroused hatred
suspicion and you just see the
destruction these important I mean
writing can help make the world a better
place because writing is how we get
shared values it it's how we get empathy
it's it can bring people together it's
one of the few things that red America
and blue America we we
can viscerally be excited by similar
stories I mean God help us if that goes
away so I know I got on my soap box and
I apologize but I was talking about
process and how important process is so
um if you can get someone to help you
with process do it it's going to
expedite your learning curve it is going
to dramatic increase your chances of
success if Bruce Springsteen could use
it we all could use it but if you can't
find someone a mentor is willing to do
it for free and you can't pay someone
like myself or someone else um it it'll
be longer and harder but you could still
do this you're fortunate to live again
in this era where you can listen to
different writers process just remember
everyone's focused on outcome and
product process is how you create
outcome improve your process improve
your outcome you don't improve your
process you keep making the same
mistakes simple as that so when John
landow took Bruce Springstein under his
wing or however it worked was that
Bruce's blind
spot his
process oh um about that earlier yeah so
for me there
strengths weaknesses and blind spots
blind spots are weaknesses you don't
know you have um weaknesses are
weaknesses you know you have I don't
know they neither of them identified
that I can't speak for Bruce but I'll
tell you what John landal did for him um
and it's something I went into great
detail in a uh a previous film courage
or an upcoming film courage video I
don't know the order of these are going
to be where I talked about there's one
question you have to answer uh for your
script to succeed or one answer or your
script will fail uh and if you haven't
yet watched that watch that film courage
video because that that singular what's
it about that is the tweak in the
process that John L used so in that
album Bruce had all of these lyrics he
had all of this experience and this is
what's important what's it about it's
not intellectual it's not theme it's
about what do people experience even if
you don't consciously know you're
experiencing it you're experiencing it
because that's what we want we want
impactful experiences and so they looked
at that and they realized there was lot
of different experiences at that time CU
Bruce had all these different songs and
in fact Boron dur run uh he shared I
think he had like 40 pages of lyrics and
I would imagine they were all just
amazing but it was the question of and
this is the most important decision
what's it about and they worked on it
for a long time and finally this is what
they came up with this is the unifying
experience of board and run and you
listen to any of the songs and you're
going to feel this it's about
friendship look at the cover art for the
album listen to the songs it's all makes
you feel friendship I mean it's a lot of
it is like what friendship felt like
when you were 20 or 22 years old in the
summer and like you had infinite freedom
and all these possibilities you know it
was a it was a
romantic friendiy feeling but everything
in that so he took those 50 pages of
lyrics and he talks about this and he
reduced it down to half a page that
focused on that piece of land that that
what's it about so in in that video that
uh you can see or will soon see when it
drops um which is the one question you
have to answer about your script I go
into great detail about uh the what's it
about um it's cool I I learned it from
Ridley Scott um and it was many years
later that I watched a documentary that
uh Bruce made about Born to Run and he
talked about it and I'm like oh yeah
yeah yeah that's what that and then of
course of course like this is just it's
the one question all artists I um have
heard Steve Martin talk about how he
creates or used to create his routine
and other it's the same Richard prior
the same thing so this is like the
secret to the creative
universe